paris right off the bat congratulations
in order that's we are hearing
congratulations because i know
it's something that is high on your
agenda is becoming a mom
yes i am looking forward to that
yeah is this true twins maybe well i
talk about it
i just actually dropped my new podcast
and this is paris
where i am discussing everything so
people can
tune in and listen to that and hear
about it all
i am not pregnant not yet
i am waiting till after the wedding um
my dress is being made right now so i
want to
make sure it looks gorgeous and fits
perfectly
you cooked breakfast because kim
kardashian came in and she cooked she's
a
obviously she knows how to cook for the
kitties will you use some of this
expertise once you have your babies here
definitely and kim and i had so much fun
in the kitchen
we both had never cooked a frittata
before in our life
so we learned how to make that together
and ever since that day i've been making
it
every single weekend for brunch for my
fiance and
he is very impressed with my new cooking
skills
how did you just decide which friends
and you have such a wide range of folks
how did you decide which friends to
invite into your kitchen
i was just looking through my phone and
just seeing like who would be fun in the
kitchen
and there was so many people i asked all
my friends everyone
immediately said yes right away and now
we have
tons of extra options for season two
because we couldn't fit them all into
the first season
um so it was just so great just to have
people come over
and be in the kitchen together and
really bond on just like a whole new
level
give me your favorites my favorite
guest or my favorite yes your favorite
guest i loved everyone i
really don't have a favorite because
everyone was so different and so much
fun and it's just
entertaining and good to be around so
they're all my favorites i was supposed
to keep this in the frigerator i've had
it out the whole time
so it's all melted great
parish you are doing a bunch of stuff i
mean you have this show you have another
peacock show i believe right and
and you have memoir coming you have so
much stuff you're doing
are you going to slow everything down
now for motherhood
i always love being a boss babe i love
working hard i'm
running a huge empire so i'm always
going to be focused on my business
um but one day when i become a mother
i'm
not going to be traveling the way that i
used to it was way too much
um so i will be doing both paris your
fashion game in the kitchen is
unbelievable
how do you keep your stuff clean because
one thing i noticed is no matter what
you do
you don't really spill that much on your
clothes
you're getting your feathers and
everything yeah i think it's fun because
i think this is definitely the most
fashionable cooking show to ever
exist and usually obviously i would not
be
dressed you know the nines cooking
for netflix i want it to be fun um but
yeah i'm just
careful but you know when i was making
those marshmallows
it did get all over me so um oh you did
i saw it on your hands it was on your
hands
yeah it got on the dress a little bit
too but
whatever that happens in the kitchen
[Music]
you guys watching at home we did this
wrong so do it the opposite way for this
part
was there anybody that you saw that you
didn't get in contact that you really
want
for the next season um
there's a lot of people who i've seen
even recently who are just like i
want to do the cooking show with you um
i just had meghan trainor here last week
for my podcast
and we were talking about doing some
cooking together
i think britney would be fun to cook
with donna would be amazing
gaga all the icons
uh you know you mentioned brittany how
have you been showing support for her
because
you have such a wealth of experience of
dealing with you know
the media and all the kinds of uh
attention that you get
how are you supporting britain we've
been in contact the past week
and i'm just sending her so much love
and support
i'm so incredibly proud of her for
being so strong using her voice standing
up for herself
just taking control of her life and i
just i love her so much
and i'm just extremely proud she's doing
okay
yes she is she is that
that is fantastic um paris
i love when you get in the kitchen with
your mom and your sister i think
that's great we get a real like glimpse
into your family dynamic
how does your how how was it cooking
with your mom because i didn't realize
you might be a better cook than your mom
we were talking about that yesterday she
actually admitted i am a better cook
than her
but i actually learned most of what i
well i didn't i don't know that much
about cooking but
lasagna and like italian food she is
amazing at cooking
and i used my grandmother's recipe to
do my splitting lasagna which i learned
from my mom
oh but yeah i'm a better pup
person you're such a like you're a
mobile and you constantly have these
ideas and ways to promote
and make i mean make money and for show
ideas
what will the next phase of your life
look like because i'm very curious you
know i look at someone like jessica alba
who came up with honest you know
and i i just i can only imagine what
kind of ideas paris hilton will
well just alone during this year i've
launched
six new businesses and i'm building a
media
company right now so i have my deal with
warner brothers
um and we're having we have two shows in
production right now
and my podcast company with iheart so
i have a couple of podcasts that are
coming out separate from this is paris
that i'm producing as well
and just all the tech that i'm investing
in and
beauty beauty lines and products and my
29 fragrance is about to come out
and just writing my new book and my
second album
it's just a lot i don't i literally need
clones
to get all this done but somehow i'm
doing it and
it's just i think something that runs in
my blood just working hard and being
successful is something that really
brings
a lot of happiness into my life paris
not that i'm one that should be giving
you advice but once the babies come
it changes everything have you heard
that
yes i've heard that my sister and i talk
about it a lot
but what does she say just that it
changes your whole life completely and
it's just
the true meaning of life and brings you
just so much joy and so much love that
you
could never even have imagined before so
i'm
i just can't wait for that day one day
and do you think your great relationship
with your mom and how close your family
is will also
play a part we've always been extremely
close
i'm so blessed that my parents are still
together
they've been together since they're
teenagers fell in love so it's really a
relationship that i look up to
and i don't know i just i love that
carter is so close with my family as
well and
just excited to join our families all
[Music]
together